yeah so thank you for that oh thank you
for teaching me and I say that ask you a
question
yep how strong am i all right I'm gonna
put this at a record I will say you are
deceiving because you thought I was a
fat [ __ ] no no no I just I'm saying I
thought I could manipulate you easier
nah bro you have this weird thing here a
lower hip that it really carries he
knows where to places weight wrestling
wrestling oh no wonder it's called
weight distribution yep and you go this
way I go that way and I take all my fat
I put it on one side yeah I control my
fat damn yeah and then also I've been
it's really just tired and lots of days
ago lately men understand generally just
kind of fatigued and tired man just in
general like live career just in general
mentally tired psychologic retired right
now man that's a sign of depression yeah
you don't have depression yes I do there
smiling you're smiling
it's called that's the biggest sign of
depression oh that's balling what flower
shielding usage fart first that you saw
her she called flower shielding you know
that I know what that means it's when
you you're happy I mean you're sad but
then you your face looks like it's happy
like a lit flower like a blooming flower
oh that's sad
it's very sad I have been doing all my
life man 25 maybe as a baby like I was
smiling stuff I really wanted to cut
myself with razor blades come here I was
coming out of the womb oh hello how was
the first emo dude Wow
establish yeah like mascara under my
eyes I listen to Suze in the benches
back in 1971 you don't think they were
around then out of the womb and yeah
there were kids too
Siouxsie and the Banshees hate Siouxsie
and the Banshees there are I yeah die I
was listened a little GBV earlier you
know what that is
no guided by voices bro you know though
no gbb is a band of Dayton Ohio and
there are cut garage rocky just loaf I
you know me it's really good bro you
know um Kurt Loder from MTV ones called
the lead singer Robert Palmer from GBV
mozart bro
mozar
yeah because he's so prolific bro that's
how I am when I'm lasted a circle an
entire and design don't they play like
pick-up basketball at a particular party
Saturday Saturday my friend Jensen drove
all the way over there to take this play
back but be ball with them do you ever
play ball with them I don't know do you
know how to play ball you have to know
I've never I've never made a bet basket
in my life have you shot before oh yeah
a thousand a what nothing one come on
can we play horse then that's the one
sport I was not made to play I always
yeah well never date a cop tunnel
syndrome yeah I mean yeah I have copper
colon syndrome I always used to say I
would never date a guy who didn't know
how to shoot a basket well you've said a
lot of things like that you're dating
the one who's never met a shot never say
never children never seen
[Music]